good afternoon counselors welcome to mid
Suffolk District Council's cabinet
meeting apologies for absence number C
thank you declarations of interest by
councillors no thank you
item 3 mca / 19 / 10 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 12th
of june for accuracy only does anybody
have any comments on pages 1 to 6
because the Whitehead oh thank you on
page 2 section 8 at the very start where
the word says details of the faithful
variances that should really read
details of the major variances because
all the major variances rents blame
whether they were favorable or
unfavorable I mean the reality is that I
think most than were favorable bar the
ICT which I pointed out they won't want
to give the impression I just basically
very details are just available there
and sister if print book could be
changed to read major variances please
thank you are you happy for me to sign
item four questions by councillors item
five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition ski dome received
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint order
and standards community there when item
seven forthcoming decisions list is it
being handed out item 8 MCA / 19 / 11
the holy neighborhood plans and I asked
the cabinet member for planning to
introduce the report think about a pill
this support updates cabinet on the
progress of the holy neighbourhood plan
and sets out two recommendations one the
parish council modified that their plan
in accordance with Examiner
recommendations and to subject to
satisfactory completion of the above the
plan be advanced to a referendum this
neighbourhood plan becomes the sixth
such plan in mid Suffolk to be presented
to cabinet for approval to go forward to
local recruitment referendum you may
recall that a similar report which
discussed
Thurston's plan came before as just a
few weeks ago but returning to Olli
officers have been working with the
parish council to help and modify their
plan in accordance with the examiner's
report and that work should be completed
within the next couple of days the
parish council are therefore addressing
the first recommendation a reminder also
that with the report within the report
before you paragraph 4.2 summarizes the
key consultation date paragraphs four
point three to four point eight eleven
cover the examination process with the
examiners key findings summarized at
paragraph four point seven and that
paragraph four point fourteen reminds us
that if this plan receives a majority
yes vote at the local referendum the
District Council is obliged to adopt the
plan as part of our development plan
framework for the designated area I mean
that's it basically so I commend this
neighbourhood plan to you and I asked
the cabinet endorse the recommendations
as set out and report I'd like to invite
councillor eben
oh sorry councillor Brewster
more than happy to second that proposal
madam chairman thank you very much
I'd like to my cancer Eberle is a ward
member for hauling to say a few words
thank you very much
councillor um there's been a lot of work
put in to get to this stage and
interestingly both by new residents to
the parish and and those that lived
there all their lives and their
grandparents and if they're all their
lives and they've undertaken an awful
lot of work looking at how the parish
will evolve over the next 20 years there
have been some really good effective
engagement and now we're looking to
follow that through on having the
housing outcomes that the parish needs
really especially for ensuring that
young people can stay within the village
and that older people can downsize to
dwellings within within the village so
particularly I'm following through on
housing outcomes which obviously also
will contribute towards the joint Local
Plan but also the other outcomes that
have mentioned in the neighbourhood plan
that has been identified through the
consultation and engagement with
residents so we're looking forward to a
referendum as soon as as soon as
possible
and hope that that will achieve a yes
result and we can take it forward from
there thank you very much
canceller flu say something to liven
things up I haven't looked specifically
at the draught local plan to see whether
what Holly is proposing in terms of its
neighborhood plan aspirations conforms
with what's in the joint local plan and
can I just ask possibly our officers or
can say he burned whether that's the
case um if I may just that it it it
isn't mentioned within the joint local
plan and that's one of the things that
we raised with Robert Hobbs was that
there it hadn't been given how close it
was to being made and that this this
cabinet meetings only kind of a couple
of weeks after the joint local plan
count you know Draft has gone out for
consultation but we had met with Robert
Hobbs last week to try and remedy that
and make sure that was included but it
but housing numbers that are in the that
relate to that neighborhood plan they're
mentioned within the joint local plan
are the same that are in you know that
correspond to what's within the the
document here but I don't if officers
might have them more better solution all
I was going to say was that through the
neighbor plan they're allocating three
sites and one of those Sciences
duplicated through the joint local plan
and just briefly about the timing of the
preparation the whole neighborhood can
sorry burns talked about the work that's
got into that and there's been a lot of
progress made during the course of last
year which is why the and through this
year by with the plans witness now and
its timing
in terms of how the neighbor plans come
forward and where we were at the time
with and where we are now with the
emerging joint local plan so there's
this there's a listen crossover between
the two in terms of allocations and then
we'll just have to see how things pan
out after that okay thank you I gather
this it's obviously an iterative process
but that's on track to work which is the
main thing thank you thank you so I've
had some council reborn' sorry can
someone if I might ask a question I just
wondered that residents are keen for
this to go forward as soon as possible
so I wondered when was the date likely
for a referendum if officers were able
to answer that thank you I've been
having ongoing discussions with the
corporate manager for electoral services
so there they're aware of the request to
have the referendum be effective before
that school term starts again parish
counts of made really good progress in
terms of modifying the plan there's a
few last-minute things that need to be
done over the next few day so I'm
helping them with some maps at the back
and getting some maps into the back of
the plan in a presentable format we
should be in a very good position
hopefully to an organized and announce a
referendum date the not too distant
future just mine for the fact that we've
got to give clear 28 working days notice
of the referendum so to achieve the date
they want we would ideally need to do
something I think before the 19th of
July we should be okay with that
thank you so I will have a proposer and
a seconder and the recommendations that
Hawley Parrish counts will be requested
to make the necessary modifications to
their neighborhood plan in accordance
with the examiner's recommendations and
then that subject to the satisfactory
completion of the above to be agreed by
the corporate manager for Satori
strategic planning the neighborhood plan
the advance to a local referendum
covering the designated plan area all in
favor please vote thank you thank you
and we'll get that out to referendum as
soon as we can
item nine a resolution to exclude the
public which term includes the press
don't have a proposer sorry I'm
proposing need to have a second all in
favor